- I’m here for the…
[sigh] Wild Card Games.
- Hey, guys, Tom Brady is here for the wild card?
- WOAH
- Good
- Did he get lost?
- OH HEY, OLD PAL,
I WILL CHOP OFF MY PENIS TO BEAT YOU.
- [All together:] VRABEL, NO!
- His hand actually looks pretty good.
- Are you sure you want to go all-in with him?
- I can’t believe I’m not out with the bye teams.
- CAN WE ORDER OFF THE KIDS MENU EVEN THOUGH
WE’RE IN OUR 20s?
- I want…
IT ALL.
- Is this old man with your party?
- I think?
- For now
- It’s a pleasure to meet you, Drew Brees.
- Aight, I got a full house then.
- We have an empty house,
except for Boston Scott.
- Our whole team is wicked banged up.
- I raise you eight.
- And I’ll lateral!
- I’m not sure you know how to play this game.
- Mr. Rodgers, did you play before they invented the yellow first-down line?
- You know that line is just on TV?
- [Together:] I can see it.
- Hey, babe, Garopps needs another drink.
- NO! NO! NOT AGAIN. TAYSOM, START THE CAR.
- UNDER PRESSURE, I RESPECTFULLY FOLD.
- I gave it everything I had.
- Aight.
- WHAT?! NOT THE TITANS.
- HERE YOU GO, TOMMY BOY!
- [All together:] NOOOO.
- Hey, what's up? It's me, Aaron Rodgers.
You know, they guys who's always making sweet comebacks.
You should subscribe to Bleacher Report so you can always
come back to watch more videos.
- Ok, thank you Aaron, that was great.
Hey, see if we can get someone young, like Lamar Jackson.
You know, someone who like fits our demo a little better.